[Música]
salud en directo américa ya está lista
para hablarnos de la salud mental más
romeros a la mar bienvenida feliz mañana
de martes como ya lo adelante vamos a
hablar de la salud mental a qué riesgo
se enfrentan los trabajadores de la
salud mar pues es indiscutible hay
varios estudios que lo muestran los
profesionales médicos tienen tasas más
altas de suicidio que la población
general especialmente las mujeres
médicas hay un estudio que se publicó
recientemente en la revista science
research elaborado por un grupo de
expertos en españa y que arrojaron
algunos datos algunas cifras nuevas
repasemos la tasa de la población
general de suicidio ronda el 0 8% en
españa' en médicos puede llegar hasta el
13 por ciento pero es que esto no es
todo sino que en las mujeres que se
dedican a esta profesión esto es todavía
más y es que la tasa llega a ser hasta
un 75 por ciento mayor en las mujeres
médicas que en la población general
pudimos hablar con la principal autora
del estudio maría irigoyen que para que
nos explicara un poco mejor cómo es de
este fenómeno las mujeres médicos
sabemos por la literatura anterior que
existen factores de cierta
predisposición a mayores tasas de
depresión sabemos que también hay una
mayor dificultad para pedir ayuda cuando
presentan malestar psíquico también hay
un acceso a metodología más violenta y
una dificultad para la identificación
entre la transición de radiación suicida
y el intento de suicidio por otro lado
en muchas ocasiones se presentan
dificultades para pedir ayuda ya que se
suele pensar que puede ser un riesgo
para perdir pero desde su licencia
médica para estar habilitado para la
profesión también se suman aspectos
relativos a las dificultades para la
conciliación familiar la promoción en el
ámbito laboral y desarrollar su
profesión con garantías de estabilidad
entonces esos factores generales no que
nos explican esto es que es una
profesión con mucho estrés con mucho
agotamiento y también con malas
condiciones laborales bajo mucha presión
a todo esto se añaden pues estas
barreras por temas de género que nos
explicaba la doctora lo más importante
además destacar también es que estos
datos raúl se recogieron entre el 2005 y
el 2014 fue desde la pandemia entonces
veamos lo que va a suceder dentro de
unos años también con los efectos de
esta pandemia que al menos ha hecho que
arrojamos algo de luz o que volvamos a
poner sobre la mesa el tema de la salud
mental dentro de los profesionales
sanitarios y que pues al menos hablemos
de este tema que ayuda al menos a que
deja de ser un tema tabú y así la gente
pueda pedir ayuda con un poco más de
facilidad marc entonces nosotros ahora
cambiamos de información gracias por
poner eso sobre la mesa porque hoy se
conmemora el día contra el cáncer
infantil le preguntó entonces cómo
afecta esta dolencia a todos los niños
del mundo y américa latina pues son
cifras especialmente dolorosas raúl no
sólo por la magnitud sino también por lo
que sabemos que implica para estas vidas
y estas familias ha habido muchos
avances en el mundo actualmente se
diagnostican unos 400.000 casos nuevos
en el mundo ha habido muchos avances
pero estos avances no están al alcance
de todos y esa es una de las cifras más
dramáticas que traemos hoy y es que la
tasa de supervivencia a los cánceres
infantiles en los países de ingresos
altos ronda el 80 por ciento una cifra
que va hasta el 20% en el caso de los
países de ingresos bajos y de ingresos
medios una diferencia abismal en el caso
de américa latina estamos alrededor del
55 por ciento y nos quedamos en la
región para repasar también los datos de
este tipo de enfermedades aquí el cáncer
infantil supone el 87 por ciento de las
muertes todas las muertes que se
registran en menores de 20 años esos son
unas 10 mil víctimas cada año es muy
importante destacar que una de las
principales diferencias entre el cáncer
infantil y el que sufren los adultos es
que el cáncer infantil es mucho más
difícil de detectar y también de
prevenir porque no afectan factores de
riesgo factores condicionales
ambientales como el tabaco el alcohol o
la exposición a contaminantes por
ejemplo y eso hace que sea mucho más
difícil de pues tener a tiempo esa
atención médica que se requiere en
algunos síntomas a los que estar alerta
si sirve de algo es fiebres acefalías
intensas y que duren mucho tiempo
dolores óseos y pérdida de peso que no
se pueda explicar por otros factores
terminamos ahora en suiza- esta sección
de salud del día de hoy marc el país
rechazó prohibir la experimentación
científica
y médica en animales le pregunto cuál es
el debate alrededor de toda esta
cuestión pues hay unos grupos tanto de
médicos como de activistas que dicen que
realmente esta experimentación en los
animales no es necesaria para el avance
de la ciencia escuchamos las
alternativas que ofrecen
los estudios preliminares deberían ser
meticulosos y deberíamos usar métodos
alternativos como bio chips cultivos
celulares cultivos de órganos también
simulaciones de computadores estudios
epidemiológicos usar todas las
posibilidades
y sólo cuando estemos totalmente seguros
deberíamos no experimentar en humanos
sino empezar las primeras aplicaciones
en humanos
es importante destacar por ejemplo que
en suiza- murieron alrededor de 560 mil
animales por experimentos científicos
sólo en 2020 una cifra que en realidad
se ha reducido significativamente en los
últimos años porque ha habido unas
ciertas mejoras pues en el tratamiento
de estos animales han experimentado
también se ha avanzado en estas
alternativas para evitar usar animales
en estudios científicos y eso es lo que
defienden pues los que están del otro
lado no que estas alternativas todavía
no están listas para estudios a gran
escala y que lo que hace falta es ser
más transparentes regular el buen trato
de los animales un último dato y es que
suiza no olvidemos el lugar donde ha
sucedido este referendo es un centro
farmacéutico esta industria supone hasta
el 9 por ciento del pib del país
entonces también hubo mucha influencia
por parte de la industria farmacéutica
para que este referendo no pasará más
gracias entonces por toda la información
las nuevas mañanas con más salud en
directo américa de france 24